now let's go to Florida where Kevin
Frazier is rocking some board shorts
because he is first on the set of the B
watch movie tough day at work Kevin look
at the company you keep
Nancy this is my life I'm in Florida
hanging out with Dwayne Johnson is at
Camp Rock and is there a better movie to
be on than Baywatch no no just to be
clear with the world there is not a
better movie to be on right now than
Baywatch especially with this dude this
is where it's having let's take a moment
to look at the shape that this guy came
in this guy motivates you to workout
started following him on Instagram he's
an animal you're playing the character
to David Hasselhoff like Mitch did you
talk to David yes and I got to tell you
David Hasselhoff The Hoff has been
amazing I mean from day one he's been so
supportive he's like if there's one guy
who could play me only one guy yeah it's
the rock I love that tell me about your
character um I play Matt Brody he's sort
of the like the brash young recruit he
doesn't necessarily see eye to eye with
Mitch and many things but no I think
he's a prick yeah I can't stand it Zach
did you have on a red white and blue
all-american bathing suit there yeah I
would flash you guys Bob we Don